from the daily wire it says san
francisco mayor london breed a democrat
was photographed at a jazz club earlier
this week indoors and without a mask
despite a city-wide mandate
let's play the video of her here
as i read this report from the daily
watch you can see her there she's
there's not a mask in sight
and they are indoors and they're packed
in tight
and there's someone singing there
exhaling
vigorously spraying his uh aerosol
particles all over this crowd of
maskless people this is a really
dangerous thing going on
um
and this was last week
when asked on friday about her defiance
of the mass mandate breed responded with
excuses that wouldn't fly for anyone
else including a denunciation of the
fund police we have her excuses
um yeah the next day she was talking to
the media
and
in fact her entire she goes on for like
five or six minutes defending herself
and i'm not gonna play the entire thing
but here's a minute and a half
of her offering excuses
for defying her own mask mandate
and uh you just have to listen to this
let's listen
i had a good time at the black cat
and i think it's sad that um this is
even a story um the fact is um
there was something that was really
monumental that occurred
and that is tony tony tony
the original members the brothers
rafael sadiq
and dwayne wiggins
who have not performed in public for i
believe at least over 20 years
they are just really
um some of the most incredible artists
in the history of this country and the
bay area in particular
and the fact that that is getting lost
here is very unfortunate not to mention
the incredible trumpeter
maurice mobetta brown
who
is just phenomenal these incredible
musicians who performed and who really
uplifted the spirits of not just myself
but all the people who were there
and from my perspective
you know i was there i was eating and i
was drinking and i was sitting with my
friends and everyone who came in there
was vaccinated so the fact that we have
turned this into a story about being
massless no i'm not going to sip and put
my mask on sip and put my mask on sip
and put my mask on eat and put my mask
on
while i'm eating and i'm drinking i'm
gonna keep my mask off
okay well she was having a good time and
besides
dwayne wiggins
almost there
come on dwayne wiggins was there and
there was and there were incredible
trumpeters
i mean
look
is that not enough for you people
yes we're saying that it's a deadly
pandemic and you know if you walk
outside without a mask on you might die
and
yeah your kids have to go to school
every day in a mask
right but uh but dwayne wiggins was at
the club
and she was having a good time
she later on she talks about i don't
know if she said it there or not because
i was only barely paying attention but
she's she accuses the the people who are
telling her that she should obey her own
rules she's calling them the fun police
and she says that she was getting in the
spirit you know
she was just vibing to the jazz music
man chill out all right
and what is she gonna do
take you know take pull the mask down
take a sip of the drink pull the mask
back up pull it down take a sip who
would do that that's crazy i mean that's
insane
it's crazy to expect anyone to do that
i mean that's exactly what they tell you
to do on planes though
it's they tell you that explicitly they
say pull your mask down take a sip and
pull it back up those are the that's
verbatim instructions from flight
attendants on planes now she's not on a
plane granted but has has mayor london
breed come out
and
uh said how she feels about these kinds
of regulations on planes
she is apparently against the federal
guidelines on planes
she should be against them
but maybe she should say that out loud
well she only says it out loud in
defense of herself not in defense of
anybody else
now of course as always with these uh
with these coveted hypocrites
the things they're saying
in defense of their behavior
if you're to
consider that in a vacuum
it makes sense
i don't have a problem
i'm not the one with a problem of
someone has a problem with someone going
to
a nightclub and having a drink with
their friends and hanging out without a
mask on
all of that makes perfect sense
the problem of course is that those
excuses
would not fly for anybody else in san
francisco
no one else is allowed to do that
no business
is allowed to say in san francisco i'm
not going to abide by the mandates
because i just want my customers to have
a good time
they should be allowed to say that but
they can't
only mayor london breed can say that
because all animals are equal but some
are more equal than others to quote
animal farm
um animal farm which by the way i i
think if we're looking for an orwell
comparison and everyone goes to 1984 and
there's a lot there's you know certainly
a lot that's analogous there many
comparisons but i think animal farm more
and more
is the better comparison
um but she doesn't apologize
that's the other thing we always see
with democrats in general never
apologize just double down
maybe a lesson there for the rest of us
more hypocrisy um on covid the emmys
were last night and we're just going
through all of the you know awards
ceremonies and galas and the vmas
last week no one no one cares about any
of this nobody watches any of it anymore
but they're still gonna you know they're
still gonna throw these really even they
don't have the ratings anymore to
justify it but they're still going to
throw these parties for themselves
um
because it makes them feel important and
that's what it's really all about but
they were indoors
maskless
at the emmys and then seth rogen gets up
there and he calls them out for this
he's getting a lot of credit for this on
online you know the social media is
impressed with seth rogen for his
courage and standing up there and
calling out his fellow celebrities for
their covet hypocrisy but i'm not quite
i'm not
quite as impressed as everybody else
seems to be let's listen to seth rogen
first
um anyway good to be here at the emmy
awards let me start by saying there is
way too many of us in this little room
what are we doing
they said this was outdoors
it's not
they lied to us
we're in a hermetically sealed tent
right now
i would not have come to this
why is there a roof
it's more important that we have three
chandeliers than that we make sure we
don't kill eugene levy tonight
yeah they're
that's perfect because they're laughing
about their hypocrisy
there's no courage in that for seth
rogen he's
just he's saying yeah we're hypocrites
isn't that hilarious and everyone's
laughing hysterically at it
he said i wouldn't have come to this if
i had known
really when you're like walking down the
red carpet and you've got your fancy
orange suit on you you didn't notice the
building you you could walk and you
could leave any time
do they have you at gunpoint on stage
i wouldn't be here right now if i knew
it was going to be like this and then he
stays there for another four and a half
hours
yeah that's what we have to understand
they
think
that their hypocrisy is funny it's just
a joke
this is
there's nothing remarkable about that
except that they're doing it on tv
with the cameras rolling laughing about
their own own hypocrisy
but they don't care
here's what we have to understand about
the the elites they they just don't care
if you're upset about it
mayor london breed
i hate to even call her an elite as the
mayor of
that
garbage craphole san francisco but
you know
in a sense of being
in charge of the city she is so they
don't care
if you're upset about it
they don't care if i'm upset about it
because to them we are sub-human we
don't our our opinions don't matter at
all
and all of these rules are for us
because we can't be trusted see mayor
breed
she can make judgment calls
and she knows that she's vaccinated and
she knows that this is a reasonable
thing to do and it's not a great risk
and everything else and she just wants
to have a go go and have a good time
that's discernment that's a judgment
call she can do that she can make that
judgment call she trusts herself
she trusts her friends to do that
but she doesn't trust you because you're
nothing but a peon
you're barely human to her
that's the way they view it well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content